I would like to talk to you about the
sausage principle the theory that says
if you love something never find out how
it was made well tonight I would like to
show you my sausage wait wait this is my
sausage the 2014 FIFA World Cup okay the
World Cup starts this week and I am both
excited and extremely conflicted about
it now I know in America soccer is
something you pick your ten-year-old
daughter up from but but for me and
everyone else on earth it's a little
more important soccer had become
d'azyr's religion in Colombia soccer was
a religion football is a religion here
soccer or football like we say it's a
religion yeah and they're not
exaggerating when David Beckham got a
tattoo of Jesus the response of most
soccer fans was that that's huge for
Jesus that's that's a big deal for him
hey here's here's my conflict the World
Cup is one of my favorite things but
it's organized by these guys
FIFA you either know it as the
fédération Internationale de Football
Association or that soccer video game
you have but for American viewers who
may never have encountered them FIFA is
a comically grotesque organization in
fact telling someone about the inner
workings of FIFA for the first time it's
a bit like showing someone two girls one
cup yeah you do it mainly so you can
watch the horrified expression on
people's faces
because let's start where FIFA's current
World Cup is about to take place
Brazil Brazilians are excited about
everything this is how they celebrate
the fact that it's just about to be Lent
they love the concept of giving up
chocolate temporarily they're also the
biggest soccer fans on earth so they
must be thrilled at the prospect of
hosting the World Cup there's been
months of unrest in some of the cities
for villas or slums with clashes between
police and residents here people
demonstrated against Brazil holding the
World Cup that makes no sense why would
you be unhappy hosting the thing that
you love the most in all the world the
government has spent more than eleven
billion dollars getting ready the United
States team will play its second game
here in the city of Manaus in this
brand-new 270 million dollar stadium
Manaus is so remote that it's almost
impossible to reach by car which is why
officials had to have the stadium
materials brought in by boat shipped
across the Atlantic from Portugal and up
the Amazon River okay that does seem
like a waste of money especially when
you consider that that stadium is only
going to be used for for World Cup games
there's also no team in Manaus that can
fill it afterwards at which point it
becomes the world's most expensive bird
toilet
no wonder Brazilians are so upset
especially when you think about what
they are actually getting in return well
in their gonna make money as well as
we're worried this ng FIFA makes the
money this is where the controversy is
the country usually doesn't make money
FIFA the organization of the World Cup
is who makes the money yep Brazil let me
put this in terms you might understand
think of money as pubic hair and FIFA as
wax they're gonna be all over you during
the World Cup but when they go they're
taking all the money with them
including some from places you didn't
even know you had any money leaving you
teary eyes going Jesus what happened
here what happened I'm never doing this
again because here are FIFA's tax
demands for prospective host countries
it is FIFA and it's FIFA subsidiaries
that are fully exempt from any tax
whatsoever levied at whatever level
state level municipality level all sorts
of taxes consumption taxes income taxes
you name it it's all attempt that's
right by Brazil's own estimates they're
allowing FIFA to forego 250 million
dollars in taxes somewhere Wesley Snipes
is going so soccer was the answer God it
seems so obvious now now now FIFA says
they leave a lot behind which they do
like new laws because you see once upon
a time Brazil did this in 2003 the
Brazilian government banned alcohol from
stadiums because of the enormous ly high
death rate amongst fans that seems like
a good idea
potentially lifesaving even the only
problem is Budweiser is one of FIFA's
key sponsors and they sell a product
they reflexively insist on calling beer
and FIFA seemed anxious to protect
Budweiser from a law designed to protect
people
which is why FIFA Secretary General went
to Brazil with a simple message I'm
sorry to say and maybe I look a bit
arrogant but that something will not
negotiator I mean there will be and
there must be as part of the of the law
the fact that we have the right to sell
beer is a maybe I look a bit arrogant
but how you say your laws and your
public safety is this adds a drag
and the amazing thing is here FIFA won
they successfully pressured Brazil into
passing a so-called Budweiser bill
allowing beer sales in soccer stadiums
and at this point you can either be
horrified by that or relieved that FIFA
wasn't also sponsored by cocaine and
chainsaws and Brazil Brazil is lucky cuz
you're lucky
at least they just had FIFA force
alcohol on them when South Africa hosted
the World Cup four years ago FIFA forced
the creation of the FIFA World Cup
courts which sound funny annoyed it's
like going to the World Series and being
dragged in front of Judge Phillie
Phanatic except FIFA's courts were no
joke to Zimbabweans who robbed foreign
journalists on a Wednesday were arrested
on a Thursday and began 15 years L
sentences the next day that is
unsettlingly fast that's like when you
order Chinese food and it comes five
minutes later thanks very much but that
was too quick you didn't have time to
make this properly and there is a
certain irony in FIFA setting up any
kind of justice system given the
scandals that have dogged it over the
years football's governing body is
trying to tackle its shady inner
workings by suspending two executives on
corruption charges the FIFA scandal
rumbles on Jack Warner who was at the
center of bribery accusations has
resigned as vice president there's been
so many corruption scandals that FIFA
have had to deal with bribery and FIFA
go together like peanut butter and jelly
yeah but they shouldn't though peanut
butter and jelly are supposed to go
together FIFA and bribery should go
together like peanut butter and a child
with a deadly nut allergy no no it's for
your brother
I like it do you think FIFA can't get
any more cartoonishly evil this is their
headquarters actual boardroom that's
right
FIFA apparently modeled where they meet
on the war room from dr. Strangelove
that is Exhibit A for an organization
that does not give a what you think
about them and yet the head of FIFA
maintains that they are merely a humble
nonprofit organization we are a
nonprofit organization and we have to
remain a non-profit organism nonprofit
with over a billion dollars in the bank
yeah but this is a reserve a reserve a
reserve of a billion dollars when your
rainy day fund is so big you've got to
check it for swimming cartoon ducks you
might not be a not profit anymore but
that by the way
is Sepp Blatter and even his name should
have been a red flag if your name is set
at the bare minimum
you've strangled someone in a bar fight
that's just a fact I let me just give
you a taste of Sepp Blatter as a human
being recently he was asked how should
women's soccer be made more popular he
said well they should wear shorter
shorts great idea
put the ladies in hot pants call it foxy
soccer and while you're at it tighten up
the jerseys maybe replace the ball with
a plate of hot wings and KITT let's just
open her hooters FIFA FIFA the humble
non profits even recently spent 27
billion dollars to fund United passions
a fictionalized version of their history
starring for some reason Tim Roth as
Sepp Blatter and this movie like FIFA
itself looks terrible
will be the fédération Internationale de
Football Association FIFA the first war
Cup will be held in Uruguay you have
everything you need to run a family but
you know the slightest error and you're
up
who makes a sports film where their
heroes are the executives and the crazy
thing is you don't need two hours and
Tim Roth because the greatest film about
Sepp Blatter has already been made it's
ten seconds long and it's on YouTube
wonderfully that is the one time you can
genuinely say I'm glad that old man fell
off that stage but perhaps the worst
part of FIFA is not even its past or its
present its its future because the host
of the 2022 World Cup has already been
decided do we know to organize the 2:22
FIFA World Cup is Qatar Qatar there's
between 1 and 50 reasons why that is an
awful idea summer temperatures in Qatar
can reach some 50 degrees Celsius a
difficult environment to hold a
professional sporting than outdoors 50
degrees Celsius is 122 degrees
Fahrenheit you are hosting the World Cup
somewhere where soccer cannot physically
be played that's like if the NFL chose
to host the Super Bowl in a lake now
that there are no allegations that some
fee for executives took bribes to put
the World Cup in Qatar and I hope that's
true because otherwise it makes
literally no sense and not just because
of the weather but because of the
working conditions guitar is a slave
state in the 21st century a migrant
worker can't leave the country without
an exit visa that visa has to be
approved by his employer who has your
passport and a bottle they know each
other so you're trapped here we've got
coffins coming home every day more than
a worker per day on average is dying
conservatively from the figures of just
two countries India and Nepal more than
4,000 workers will die before a ball is
kicked off in 2022 so what you're
essentially saying is the Qatar World
Cup is shaping up to be the most deadly
Middle East construction project since
this one and and by this point I hope
I've proven to you that FIFA is just
appalling and yet here's their power I
am still so excited about the world
next week and it's very hard to justify
how I can get so much joy from an
organization that's caused so much pain
other than going back to right where we
started soccer or football like we say
it's a religion but it's not just that
it's an organized religion and FIFA is
its Church just think about it its
leader is infallible it compels South
American countries to spend money they
don't have building opulent cathedrals
and it may ultimately be responsible for
the deaths of shocking numbers of people
in the Middle East
but-but-but-but the millions of people
around the world like me it is also the
guardian of the only thing that gives
their lives any meaning and if that
comparison does not make Americans love
soccer then frankly nothing will